i had a few questions relating to my
family life for guys who joined the
seals
my boyfriend is interested in taking the
pass so this is coming from
the girl oh okay interesting
jockey you've mentioned being married
while a seal was it hard on you
on you and your wife and family advice
for a newlywed
sof candidate that stands for soft
special operations forces
there you go so this is actually
this was two questions and basically
from the other side and pete by the way
everyone that's asked can i bring my
wife on here
my wife has given the the stern negative
she's not coming you know why because
she's a legit quiet professional
she's just a legit quiet professional
she doesn't want any of this
glory no she did it just because she
loves the job
so my wife has said no and after and
someone said you know i said
uh went back and forth with somebody on
social media
and they said hey flanker hey ben she's
she knows this game bro she's not gonna
get flanked it's super easy
um but what i'm doing is kind of playing
a long-term game i'm playing some seeds
and whatnot trying to get her
maybe to think about how she could help
some other folks out there so you know
we're trying to work through
yeah there is some flanking activity
going on we're gonna see where it goes
uh but to this question being married to
a guy that's in special operations or in
the seal teams or whatever
it is a hard life in
many ways and you know the seal teams we
had a 90
divorce rate by the way a 90 and i think
it's come down a little bit i'm not 100
sure
i don't know what the current numbers
are to date but man when i was a young
kid
everybody was divorced you know guys
were just getting married and divorced
all the time
so here's the here's the couple things
that i would tell you that i think made
made my marriage last right aside from
my wife being awesome of course right
first credit but here's a couple things
number one um you have to respect the
fact that the job is
the number one priority and that is
completely different
from what a lot of people think and i
don't mean to be offensive by that
by saying that but the job has to be
number one and for me and i've said this
before
on interviews the job was the most
important thing to me
and my wife didn't take
offense to that she didn't when i said
hey i'm going to work but it's saturday
it doesn't matter
you know oh i'm going i'm not going to
be coming home tonight why
i'm going to work and then i'm going out
with my friends
because we're going to go and hang out
because that's what we do
and she never would get offended by that
instead she realized okay yeah his job
is the most important thing he's got to
take care of himself he's got to take
care of his guys he's got to take care
of his job
he's got to take care of the country so
i am number two that's cool you know
what i need to do is help support him
and so that is
that is what was happening and and so
what that means is
your wife in this case you young lady
that's asking this question
you need to be an independent person
right you
you need to be self-sufficient and and
that's not just self-sufficient with
you know being able to
clear the toilet when it gets clogged up
and
you know call the plumber when the water
heater breaks and
handle all that administrative stuff and
all the tasks around the house and
provide you know take care of the
finances because your
your husband's gonna be gone he's gonna
be gone he's gonna be on a workup he's
gonna be
he's gonna be gone a lot and so you're
gonna be able to handle all that stuff
and on top of that you have to be
self-sufficient
emotionally emotionally self-sufficient
where you don't
need to have this constant
uh you know constant flow of affection
coming from this guy who has a bunch of
other things to worry about
yeah right so
that's hard to do and it's hard i think
that's one of the problems i mean that's
why there's probably a high divorce rate
because it's
hard to find a a girl or a woman
that can do those things yeah right
so it's that that will make
that's part of the solution here now the
husband obviously
big things you got to do is leave
your job at work right and
don't don't bring it home with you and
i've talked about this before you know
in the seal teams you don't have to when
you get done with work you change you
put on your civilian clothes
you go home so you're not bringing that
with you that's sort of a psychological
moment to change and and get those out
but there's also the
attitude that you can carry over very
easily because
the seal teams and and special
operations in the military in general
but definitely the seal teams
is a hostile environment with your
friends your friends
are not supportive caring
nurturing friends no your friends are
just just savages right
everything they're looking for weakness
it's i mean it's all fun
but it's all just a constant it's a
constant
just battle verbal battle verbal abuse
all day long
it's fun like we're having fun with it
that's the
sixth sense of humor you know when tim
kennedy was on here and they made that
movie rage
range 15 and all all that that like kind
of sick twisted sense of humor is what
you're living in and there's a real
problem that occurs
when you take that little sick sense of
humor and that abusive personality that
you develop at work and you bring it
home
yeah and that happened to me when i went
to college
and all of a sudden i wasn't around any
team guys anymore
all day long no more team guys and then
here i am
and what do i do now i come home from
going to school all day
which was annoying and then the first
person i talked to because i didn't talk
to anyone when i went to school
unless i was asking them a specific
question about some knowledge or
some thing that was happening in a class
other than that i didn't make any
friends
so i come home and i want to socialize
what was the only way i knew how to
socialize with people
cutting them down abusing them and
that's a little bit strong but you know
definitely making comments and
and trying to have a good time through
through cutting people down yeah and so
you know and i've talked about this
before i think somebody's
kind of grabbed onto this but you know
for instance you know
before i was going to college when i was
just in the teams my wife would make
dinner whatever it is she makes it hey
cool thank you appreciate it
when i was going to school also i'm not
around team guys anymore i want to have
some fun when i come home
and you know she'd cook me something and
i would
have some comments about it right
and eventually and it was very clear
when she said this to me she didn't
think a big deal she just goes hey i'm
not a team guy you know right
you know i think i said something about
this dried chicken that she made my wife
has always had some issues getting
moist chicken made right it always
i don't know she's paranoid about food
poisoning but when she cooks it man
she cooks it big time i mean she goes
the distance
right she will cook that thing until you
know
you're you got to bring a gallon of
water to the table just to get through
the meal
so she's actually got a lot better in
the recent years
so anyways back in the day i'd say she
said oh you know
i made you some chicken and i'd say oh
can can you just go ahead and bring me
three gallons of water to the table
and then it was one of those comments
that i made one time where she says you
know i'm not a team guy
and i kind of laughed and i said oh my
gosh look what i'm doing yeah i'm
treating her like a team guy and she's
not a team guy and she doesn't need to
be treated
like that so i just put myself in check
and got myself under control and
treated my wife like the good person
that she is
so there's that there's
communication it's and this is this is a
weird thing because everyone's going to
say communication
but my point here is don't expect
communication
right don't expect communication one of
my buddies
was married and we were going on diploma
this is a long time ago
he was married he had three three kids
been married to you know married his
high school sweetheart
blah blah and he lived in coronado where
where the seal teams are
he lived there and his wife he lived
there with his wife and
one day he dropped off his car he had to
get his car worked on or something like
that
and he said this is we've been at the
seal teams for five years he's married
the whole time
been a seal team one and one time he
says to his wife hey you know he calls
her
and says hey can you come pick me up
because we got to go somewhere blah blah
and she goes yeah she says where are you
he goes i'm at the team
and she goes where is it and coronado by
the way is only like a mile long
and and so it was a classic example of
he never told his wife even where the
buildings were or what he did or
anything like that and that's just the
way it was
and a lot of successful
seal marriages that i've seen there's
not a lot of
hey this is what i did at work today and
hey this guy's a jerk and hey we're
trying to make this happen hey i got in
trouble for this
there's none of that there's just like
work and then there's what we have right
and i think that you got to separate
those two but what i'm saying is
this idea of communication happening all
the time it's not going to happen all
the time
it's not going to and i don't even know
if i don't think it's beneficial when i
was overseas i wouldn't call my you
could
you could call your wife you know
basically every day if you want to i
didn't call my wife every single day
i don't want to call my wife every day
it makes time slow down it doesn't speed
it up
just don't call call like once a week
that's what i do call my
wife once a week hey how you doing i'm
fine how's everything at home
i would just ask her questions about
home didn't didn't tell her
anything that was going on ever and just
said oh yeah how's this oh yeah did you
get the you know how's the car and did
you get the water heater fixed and how's
the kids doing in school and blah blah
blah ask her questions
because otherwise you're going to start
talking about your world and then that's
going to make them worried and concerned
and everything else and you don't want
that
so you don't need to talk to somebody
every single day that you do
that's neediness that's emotional that's
what i was talking about earlier with
with being emotionally independent right
you got to be independent you can't need
that like security of hey
call me and talk to me no actually i'm
not going to call you
i'm not going to talk to you you go do
your thing i'm doing my thing
you know on top i think it's cool if you
want to set some goals you know
together make a little team you know
you're trying to make some things happen
you're trying to make some financial
goals
or some family goals or some house goals
you know we want to get
new carpet want to put some new
wallpaper up
whatever you know want to add you know
just do stuff and and make those goals
maybe make some jiu-jitsu goals together
that's always good
my wife was really good at jiu-jitsu
she's kind of stopped training when she
started
having babies every 18 months and all
that
what but you know we used to have a
blast training jiu jitsu all the time
so i obviously recommend the jiu jitsu
to help all relationships
working out together is another good one
you know even if you can't get those jiu
jits together you can
you can you can just work out you know
work out together
and that's cool and then you got to give
each other some space
right got to give each other some space
the guy the guy he's a team guy he's a
special operations guy
he's going to hang with his friends
sometimes and that's the way it goes
there's nothing wrong with that
that's the way things work and you know
what she's gonna go do the same thing
so that's okay um
yeah so i think those are the main
things you know jp when jp was on here
he he made a good point of put put
each other first right pretty simple
point that goes a long way
yep that goes a long way yeah which is
contrary to what i said which is like
the team is going to come first but
that's your job
yeah and i think you can still put your
team as the number one priority and
doing your job as your number one
printer because that's that's the thing
i said this a million times right
hey listen darling the reason i have to
do my job well
is because this is what we do we fight
and guys are gonna be trying to kill us
so the best thing i can do for our
relationship is stay alive
yeah so that means and and not only that
but i got these guys that also need to
stay alive for their wives
so we're going to work hard we're going
to train hard we're going to play hard
we're going to know each other better
we're going to we're gonna bond and all
those things are gonna happen
and that's how i can best support this
family is by kicking ass at my job
and if you're a smart wife you'll go
that makes sense to me
yeah and it'll be okay so in putting
your job as the number one priority
you're actually supporting the family
and you're you're putting your
your spouse first because you're trying
to take care of yourself take care of
your team
so that you can come home when when it's
time to come home
yeah yeah jp made it
i mean the the put each other first
that's kind of like a like
dated it's like you got to remember that
you know because you know how like
you're on two different pages you know
oh yeah you gotta put you gotta you
gotta remind yourself yeah daily
yeah but man it helps it helps a lot
have you have you been doing that lately
implement
i liked how i like how jp put it you
know we just put each other first it's
real like dang that kind of
resonated i don't like using that word
but
it resonated you know why don't you like
using that word i don't know you know
those words
you know certain words just sound dumb
coming out of your mouth is that one of
them in my opinion
it comes down out of anyone's no out of
my
i think that sounded pretty good
actually oh thanks
all right well yeah that was a good one
good luck uh by the way
good luck uh to these guys that are
trying to get in the special operations
community
it obviously i loved it and it was
awesome for me
and i'll tell you my wife that was
definitely hard man
it was a hard it's a hard path and when
your husband's over on deployment
and you're home and guys are coming home
wounded or guys are getting killed
overseas that that's
that's gonna be that's hard and that's
one of the things that i talk about the
strength
of the spouses and the independents to
be able to deal with those hardships
when they come
that's real stuff and so to the to the
women out there that support these guys
god bless you yeah that that point you
made where
you i think it's probably just
habitually a little bit when you treat
your wife like a team guy you know
like how because that's how you're used
to like bonding with people you like you
know so in a way it's like it's good
yeah you know
yeah man it's not a joke it's not a
one-way street man you can't you can't
be doing that
i do i had the same thing because that's
how me and my brother we just that's it
the whole thing is like so you can make
make the funniest joke about the other
guy you know and then
so sarah was like our friend before we
got together so she kind of and she
would she didn't like that even from the
beginning
but once you're kind of like in the
relationship she kind of got a lot of
and she
constantly constantly like like i'm not
you're you know
and of course i'm not your brother yeah
i'm not your brother i'm not your friend
like that kind you know but but of
course if you're not looking at it as
like a two-way street
you're like wait you should be happy i'm
treating you like this you know
this is my way of showing affection
exactly right you should be happy right
no no no that's a different person
you're talking about you know
anyway